R
PUTIN'S SUCCESS.
IT IS E TION
CAMPAIGN ON STATIR
IO
THE WAR IS GOING.
"THE N Y
SPENT MORE
REVIEWING RUSSN TEIGS.ON IS THAN
CONVINCE. AS OFN,OA TVIEWERS.
JOINEDY
PIECE.
C
RUSSIA OE SINKING OF THE
FLAGTHAT YOUSED INCE.
LET'S TAKE A LOO TS.
[SPEFOREIGN LANGUAGE]
>> N
ATS ATEDY TH CE CREW
TED.
HOW DID THE STORY, AS IT WAS
TOLD TRUSSIA,
PROGRESS FROM ER
TRYING TO EXPLAIN AWAY THE
ATTACK AS  ATTACK.
ANTH
SH SHOTHANK IN
THE STORM, ATHEY I
REALLY TT AS NOT FOLDED, BU
ANK BUT THIS WAS AN
ACCIDENT AND JUS TO SAVE
FAG A SHIP.
AND NOT ONLYEQD TY'RE VEROU
OF THAT SHIP.
R ATEGIC LOSS R TH.
RU AT HOME AND SAVE ON TUTS .
>> WHAT DOES
>> YEAH, SO R ES IN TH
DID START TO
ACKNLE
HIGHER, 10,0 00ANFO PARTICULAR
OF SAILORS FROM THSH LINED
N A NICELY SEES AT
ABOUT SOLDIERS AND
SAVED FROM THE SHIP WHEN WS THA.
AND THROUGHOUT THETHEY'VE
TRIED TO
CASUALTIES, UKRAINIAN ES, AS HX
TO THEIRILIES.K
>> STATH US BECAUSE I ALSOWANT
CONVERSATIONCNST.S THKRE AT
THEIR VIEW?
IS THIS A NEW  OPAGANDA FROM WHO
SO MUCH  BECAUSE THE
RUSSIANS AND THE SOVIETS, YOU
KNOW,  BEETHIS FOR
WELL OVER 100 YEARS.
IT STARTED IN LINEN STEIN OVER
100 YEAR
SHOW AND TELOUUNM IS TO THIS DAD
ELEVISIOYOU'VE GOT THET.OF COUV
IF YOU DON'TE  ST.
PETERBURG OR
LARGER THAT'S REALLY ALL
YO
AND IT'S VERY LIMITEANYWAY.
THIS IS REALLY JUST DIERT
TECHNOLOGYBUT ESSENTIATH
OPERANDI THAT THE S  USEU AN TE
TO YOU OR SURPRISE Y
STEWART, I'MOR>> THINK WHAT SE
HE WEST IS PUTIN
B RALLIES NUMBERS
ANIT'SONO TR
UNDERSTAND WHY.
I THINK THE THING I REALLY GOT
FROM LOOKING AT ALL THE IS ADI
O SPIN EVENTS AND REALLYE'VE SS
FIRE THAT RAISE A LOT OFLAULT O
OR ANOTHER WITRUSSIA
BENT, REALLYEAICALI'VE
RELIED ON FOR
NEONAZIS, THAT'S ONE THING WE N
EVENT WHERE THERE'S CASUALHAES,S
NS
THEY WERE ABLE TO THAT WASITR T.
THAT WAS A FEATURE AND
SOMETHING WEE AWARE OF.
IT REALLY DID SEND OUT THE
>> STEVE, THERE ARA LOT OF
WHE  THEIR ENTIRE CARETR
KREMLIN.
IS IT POSSIBLE TO GE
INKING BY
STATE TV?
>> YHINK IT'S -- I TNKTHERE IS F
AN OPTRE.
, OPEN SOURC
AT
T IN THESE  SHINYWE
GOSTEWARR PUTTING ASON THAIT
THI CEAI WANT TO DO
THG.IT'S IMPORTAT.
E RE, E LIN HAS SCREWED UPN
PASTTH
ED THERE HAVE BEEN
ALSO IN AFGHANIS CCHA AN
HAVE BEEN OT
MOERS STARTED TAINT
THEIR SONS NOT COMING HOME.
THERE WAS THE SINKING OF THESUB